[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right thank you very much
where should I put this I'm gonna put it
up here y'all can check that out all
right so welcome to my talk
this is universal react applications
with redux which is the most buzzword II
title I can think of in the 5 seconds I
was trying to sign up for a talk what
happened oh we went to sleep
are we back yet alright we're back I'll
try to remember to poke that thing okay
so by way of introduction my name is
Brad I build things with react and redux
at spread fast which is based in Austin
Texas anyone from Austin shout out
excellent yes it's too hot there though
so but good on you my first passion is
actually music that's the most
embarrassing photo I've ever shown this
many people you can't really see it but
that is a true mullet
there there's a little bit you can see
and I obviously know what I'm doing
because the guitar is upside down I
promise you I know more now so if you're
into like guitar shredding videos
there's an Instagram shameless plug and
I'm also recently a dad this is my son
Remington thank you
as of July 1st so if my talk seems
underprepared it's his fault so I just
want to start out by saying I love Redux
how many of you use Redux at work I'm
assuming most of you because you came to
this talk hopefully but I just want to
say that because I feel like it gets a
lot of crap and I think it's awesome and
it has made my day job a lot easier
so why this talk I saw this tweet when
did this happen
I don't know a little bit ago mid-july
was asking is anyone doing this is
anyone using Redux on the web and
sharing their Redux code with react
native project but not sharing you
and we've been doing this for years and
I thought is this interesting for people
to know maybe actually give an
experience report and just talk about
some of the challenges and what works
well and what doesn't so this talk might
be interesting to you if you have a
Redux app and you're looking about
thinking about making a mobile app
you're looking at react native maybe
you're just curious about mobile or
maybe for some other reason you're
looking to recompose your Redux
applications together into other
applications so this is kind of what's
going to be important is to understand
the decisions that we've made is to
understand the organizational structure
so for us our org kind of looks like
this we have many different web apps
that are all standardized on react and
redux and there's a lot of different
teams and they're basically independent
we have to or in the past we've had two
mobile developers a native iOS developer
and a native Android developer and they
try to keep up you can see they're very
worried about keeping up with features
that are being deployed on the web apps
and so what we've done is added a few
people like myself who are comfortable
with JavaScript also mildly comfortable
with doing native stuff and also told
the native developers they will be
writing JavaScript which you can see
they're super excited about so how does
this work here's an example here's the
web app we're using react and redux that
stuff goes through web pack there's a
bundle that gets deployed perfect you
guys know that part what we chose to do
is I'll go in and drop a rollup config
in each of those repos and make a
separate bundle that's just the stuff
that we want to consume so we'll see
what's in that bundle is just your your
reducers your actions your selectors and
there's an asterisk which we'll talk
about later so how to make a bundle it
looks something like this you create a
new entry point and then just import
just the things that you need so here
we're importing everything from this
widget reducer and we're kind of giving
ourselves some kind of standard
structure for this package is going to
export reducers and actions and
selectors you can use whatever
format organization works for you this
is just what we do and you will not want
to import everything there's going to be
stuff that's web specific like your
router reducer if you're doing that
things that are web specific that you
will not want to import so I want to
take a second and talk about why you
should bundle or why do that because
it's not actually the standard in react
native applications to bundle your
JavaScript most react native libraries
just ship JavaScript source why would
you do that that sounds insane it kind
of is but the reasons we chose to do a
bundle is because hey it provides us a
chance to catch things at compile time
so these are things like there was one
project that had a selector that was
returning SPG's based on some state
that's obviously not something we can
use on mobile so that had to get
reflected out into the component and so
this you have a chance now to catch
things like that that aren't going to
work on mobile at compile time
the second reason which is really the
bigger reason is that a single point of
entry provides you some encapsulation so
that a developer can't just go require
into source of your application that you
shipped and use something you didn't
intend to be used in your mobile
application so I think those two things
were enough to make that choice for us
some of the issues with bundling the ES
target is weird but it's not that weird
there's react native implements its own
version of Babel helpers and so you want
to use external helpers it also
implements async/await natively and
that's because of performance and
reasons and so you don't want you want
to use external helpers and you don't
want to compile async/await
and so it's actually really easy to do
that if you're using roll-up at least
you say I want external helpers this is
your babel config and roll up and you
say transform syntax async functions so
the battle knows what you're talking
about but it won't touch it and then you
have something that you can consume in
your react native application some other
gotchas
you're obviously if you're not familiar
I'll just do a quick review the react
native is running in a JavaScript
context that does not have any access to
Dom api's or any other wave api's that
you're normally used to it is a
bare-bones
like JavaScript interpreter environment
so anything in your web code that is
referencing window or Dom like if you're
doing local storage get item as the
default value in your reducer which you
shouldn't do but if you're doing that
and I've seen that move that out just
move that into your components anything
that's web specific should probably live
in your components anyways so that's my
thought there the other part of this
which is really sort of the same thing
is if you have some static config so
most web projects can just generate a
bundle with some static config and
that's going to be the same for each
host you just make a different bundle
for each host that you deploy to right
so you can do all that at compile time
and that's easy at on mobile you're
probably going to want to hit multiple
different environments and switch
between them at runtime right you're
going to want to have some kind of like
dev settings interface where you say
okay go look at this other environment
or just for the pure effect that you
might hit you might be doing like third
tier domain stuff where this company is
on this domain this company is on that
domain and you might need to switch
between them and that's now needs to
happen at runtime rather than on at
compile time so you have to care about
that and so the solution for that is
really simple you just move it to your
components this is one possible solution
that we do is to just do the same static
config but then dispatch that from your
components and move that stuff to state
and then in your actions later on you
can select that information out of state
and it's all in sync and nice there's
probably some other ways you can solve
that but that's how we did it another
thing declaring externals this is not
really an issue so much as just a
reality so it's something to be aware of
and you should probably be aware of this
with your web bundles anyways is do you
want to declare all of your period
appendices to be external because you
can definitely end up ship
like react Tom and you didn't mean to in
your bundle and you don't want to do
that so just a friendly reminder
probably the biggest well this is not
really a huge issue at the end of the
day you can't use NPM link with the
react native packager it just doesn't
work so if you were thinking that you
could debug creating your entry point
file and your bundle and use NPM link to
nicely do that while you're consuming it
and test it in the consuming application
you can't do that and you're gonna end
up copying files on the file system
that's you'll notice this is issue
number one when they moved to Metro
bundler it was copied over from the old
react native repo so I guess you could
be a hero if you want to fix this I'm
sure there's many people who would give
you beer ah let's take a break
you will see him twice more I apologize
if you don't think he's cute he's pretty
cute though
alright so using the bundle so now we've
moved from your web application who's
making a bundle and publishing some code
to your mobile application that's trying
to consume it and so you may have only
one application that you're trying to
share in our case we were trying to
compose multiple web applications down
into one mobile application that is
trying to implement all of them in one
native app and so here you can see we're
importing reducers we're aliasing them
and we're combining them into one
reducer and you notice we export
selectors to get at each of those pieces
of state which will be important later
and then this is what a container would
look like basically what you're doing
most of your work in the mobile app is
wiring up new containers and creating
new user interface in components and
you're reusing the same actions and
selectors that you would use so here
we're importing some actions we're
importing some selectors and we create a
container and this is too much code for
one slide I apologize this is the
important bit you'll notice here we're
using reselect as anyone
use reselect how many of you are
familiar with reselect have used it okay
some hands not a ton of hands basically
the important thing to know is that a
selector is doing something to get State
right it's it's grabbing your state and
it's going dot whatever it out whatever
that whatever to get you some value out
and it does fancier things because
performance so what we're doing here you
notice we're wrapping our selectors that
we imported in a transform to get at the
state and that's because we moved State
around right those selectors would be
looking at the wrong state shape if we
didn't do this but this is an easy
solution and this that selector that we
exported before it can be a simple just
property access like it is here and it
might actually be more complex and we'll
see an example of why later on so great
this works we're done thank you bye
could this be a trap maybe there's some
gotchas so like we were just talking
about how many of you use Redux func to
do your async stuff so a lot of people
quick survey redux promise no no means
Sagas okay I think you have this problem
everywhere if you're changing your state
shape this is how we solved it with
thunks because we use thunks so the
selectors that are in your thunks
remember they're in your web app code
they depend on the shape of the state
that your web app expected in the first
place when it was written and so it's
coupled to that state shape so just an
example here let's pretend that load
which widgets uses the get page number
selector right this is going to blow up
when you try to run it in your mobile
application if you move that state
around like we did so how do you fix
this this is a bad name for a thing I'm
sorry naming is hard but this is the
name that I came up with a func adaptor
basically what it does is it wraps your
thunk it returns you another thunk you
give it a transform and it'll make sure
that when your thunk calls get state and
any it gets the transformed state and
not your original station
and then it also makes sure that when
you dispatch other thunks from that
thunk that those also get the transform
state and this works this is an example
of usage pretend that that create func
adapter exists and it does that what I
just described so you can it works kind
of like connect where you call it with
the transform it gives you a function
that you can then use to wrap your
thunks and so that's what that looks
like you can just copy this code if you
want it's just it's a small function
it's not a big deal but that exists okay
so if you we we survived that our app
can now run it can be compiled consumed
and we can actually run and dispatch
actions and things work okay so Q he's
so fat all right so this next section of
things is going to be more less like
issues and fixing things because we
already got our app working there's
going to be situations where either
because of design or because of what you
want to achieve you're going to want to
augment the behavior or enhance the
behavior that the web application gave
you to do something that's more specific
to what you want on mobile and you want
to try to do that in as least as little
obtrusive not intrusive ly as possible
so that these are the there's an example
of that so on your web application you
might have like a search and filter and
those changes are happening live you
click the buttons the request has made
it you see the results it's all changing
live but on mobile your designs maybe
have like a cancel apply pattern where
you don't want to actually make the
request until later and you want to be
able to cancel back to some old state
that's not functionality that your web
app built and you shouldn't necessarily
have to refactor your entire web app
just to get this on mobile right so how
could we do this we can use a
higher-order reducer reducer enhancer or
whatever word you want to call that this
function takes this is imaginary this is
something that we've written in our
application but here it's
imaginary we're passing in a reducer
that controls some state that we want to
be able to cancel back to and it takes
an action type to mark the value of
state that you want to potentially go
back to so like this would be the action
that you fire when you navigate to that
modal screen and then it also takes a
cancel action which tells it yeah we
actually do want to cancel back please
restore the state that you marked
previously and then your state is going
to look like this right here this is it
was flow I changed it to typescript
because of the NPM talk I guess more
people use typescript and flow but
that's okay your state's gonna look
something like this right where your
state is now wrapped into properties
mark state and state and you just want
to select out the current state and
that's the situation where remember
earlier we talked about your state
selectors when you change state around
may just be simple or they may be more
complex this is a case where it may be
more complex where you want to be able
to present the web applications code the
actual pass-through state and not this
cancelable State thing cool so we fixed
that
what's another use case maybe you want
to be able to reset data here I'm
talking about pagination this could be
any other type of situation where you
need to reset data say you have your web
app is has an interface where it's
paging data and because that's all they
were doing they're throwing the data
away every time you change the page but
on mobile the designs are that you have
an infinite scroll and you need to keep
that data around do you have to refactor
you could refactor your web application
to instead like window into that data
but remember we're trying to be
unobtrusive can we do this we can do
this in a similar way by in having a
higher-order reducer here we're here is
the case where we want to keep data
around but the consuming reducer is
throwing it away you know we can
intercept this data loaded imaginary
data loaded action we can get the old
value from state and then we can call
the reducer that we're consuming and do
some glue code to merge those together
which Java is pretty simple to do right
you
you're using like an immutable
collection you just merge those or go
the opposite way
right you could instead before you call
the reducer you're consuming clear out
the data that's there to get the paging
behavior and obviously you can solve
those in multiple different ways these
are examples of ways in which you can do
it without refactoring your web
application which for us was important
because those teams are independent of
the mobile team and we can't just go
stomping all over their code for no
reason even if we have what we think is
a good reason so this in the last part
just a friendly reminder that middleware
is cool I know some developers on my
team are kind of reticent to like write
custom middleware they think it's scary
it's not that scary
you should be using it in fact these
examples analytics and crash reporting
are right on the tutorial so friendly
reminder there but also you can use them
to implement integration with native
features like handoff and linking and so
we'll look at an example of handoff now
how that might work so does anyone
actually know what handoff is have you
ever actually used this feature like two
hands so handoff just for context is an
iOS feature where you can pass data
between your running applications and
generally it's for going from iOS to Mac
or iOS to iOS or vice versa but perhaps
a little-known feature of handoff is
that you can actually handoff from a
website from your domain to your native
application and vice versa so that if
someone is using your web app and they
pull up their phone they can actually
get a handoff recommendation says Oh
open this in my app and vice versa they
can be using your app on their phone and
then get a handoff recommendation on
their laptop that says go to this web
URL and that is pretty cool I think I
don't know why more apps don't use that
but we can imagine we could do this in
middleware without changing any of the
application logic code at all if we have
this what here is an imaginary custom
that we wrote just pretend this API
exists it basically looks like this and
are in our hand off middleware we could
you know subscribe to a hook that says
okay when we get a hand off event we get
some data in this case handing off from
the web will just get a URL that's the
only thing we'll get unfortunately but
we should be able to take that URL and
transform it into some navigation state
in our application which we can do just
by in our case we have all of our
navigation state inside of Redux but if
you were using some sort of navigator
pattern you could also just call
functions on the navigator you know do
whatever you need to do to restore that
URL presumably you have an analogue to
that URL state in your native
application and then going the other way
you can observe either you know methods
on your navigator hook into those calls
or observe navigation actions if you're
just dispatching navigation actions and
let your the handoff native module know
this is this is a URL you know you build
a URL that represents the current
navigation state and say that's the
current URL I would want the user to
resume - if they chose to do so
and that's it we didn't change any of
the web code we didn't write wrap any
actions or anything like that so use
middleware it's great cool
so in summary this has been a pretty big
success for us so far you might look at
the thunk adapter thing and say that's
crazy I can't believe you're doing that
and that it's a heck it probably is
that's okay it's working for us and
we're shipping a lot of code on mobile
really fast
so that's valuable some of the
challenges are keeping up to date with
the web projects there's a lot of things
that aren't caught in that compile step
that only get caught at runtime like
right now if they added a new if someone
again went into a reducer and said local
storage docket item it would not blow up
until we pulled in the new version of
the package and then we would have to go
back and fix it and then do it again so
that's kind of an annoying thing and is
just kind of a manual process of talking
to the teams and seeing what they're
working on so that could be better also
training I don't know if you guys have
found this
training people in react and redux if
they are not familiar with functional
programming is hard it takes a little
bit longer than I would assume it does
and that's especially true for remember
our excited mobile developers who were
thrilled to be riding with Jas before
it's especially true for them because if
you've been in that world that's a very
object oriented this is very very
different
and it is hard for them to learn they're
smart people obviously but it's just a
hard thing it's a complete paradigm
shift and so that is a challenge not
insurmountable but is a challenge some
future things that we would like to do
have automatic pull requests when new
packages are deployed this is just kind
of like a nice logistical thing that
could be great and this means we could
also write integration tests with their
thunks and make sure that everything
works right
then there's acceptance testing going
one step further acceptance testing on
mobile is hard because there at least
with react native there isn't a way to
do this headless Lee you have to use a
simulator or you'd have to go like use
react native web and render your mobile
application in a webview and then use
the web tools to do acceptance testing
which is seems to me too much work to
maintain just to get acceptance testing
on your mobile application so you're
stuck with like running in simulator and
using those api's which is hard that's
just a challenge but something that we
would like to solve and like I mentioned
before catching more things at bundle
time caching references to window
objects or Dom API is that or SVG's
things that we don't that are going to
fail at runtime we'd like to move that
catch to compile time if possible and
and then lastly I'm going to go next
door and learn about how I should
replace Redux with rxjs because
apparently that's the new hotness that's
it for me and a little bit early please
if you have questions I really want to
talk about all this stuff and if there
are better ways to do it please come
tell me if you're doing this I would
love to hear about that thing
to you very much
[Applause]